you just got back from Italy what's the
most memorable thing I was just there
recently as well it was very chaotic
because we went out on a whim and we
only had our first hotel book and then
we rented a car and drove around all of
the cities and went to like five
different cities in about a week and a
bit
um so I think it was just the variety of
seeing so many different places when
we're used to being at home all the time
and Andrea is yours your luggage yeah I
would say it was the most stressful
vacation we've been in in our life and
it was a valuable Learning lesson
because now I know how to be prepared
for trips but we lost our bags and I
never got them back and like Alex said
we didn't know where we'd be sleeping
every night and we're just driving
through a new city with a giant van in
the most narrowest streets with and
getting in many many fights with Italian
men
um so it wasn't really a vacation I saw
this motion so many times
wasn't liberating to lose your baggage
is that still the lining it was
liberating my entire life I've always
had the issue of over packing and I told
him no matter for the trip Andrea you're
gonna pack light right yeah Alex yeah
and then I see her stuffing her over but
you did the same we both had giant big
like extra baggage that we didn't need
and I'm actually very glad we lost it
because for Venice calling that around
on all the boats and through the tiny
streets and there's no Ubers
um and now it's the first time where I
can travel without checking in a bag
which I've never done before so now I've
learned what it means to pack light
because I saw that I could survive off
of Just My this sounds very dramatic but
it was really a big Learning lesson for
me the driving must have been crazy
because driving in Italy is rough the
driving was crazy I did most of it and
it would be really interesting driving
through places like Florence or even
through uh the beach areas that were
super windy because there are two-way
streets that should really only be one
way so you'd be driving this huge van
and then another car comes on a cliff
and you're just waiting for it to slowly
pass so it took all of my focus and
concentration to drive well in Italy but
it was actually really relaxing because
the hardest thing about uh making a lot
of videos online is you're always
thinking about it what's coming next and
when we were in Italy it was so chaotic
that I did not think about work for a
good week and a bit oh because you're
just we were stressed I was just trying
to Keep Us Alive
and that was kind of fun it was kind of
fun no planning nothing I wouldn't
recommend it or ever do that again but
it sounds sounds pretty awesome and we
even randomly ran into two friends of
ours who were in the same city and we
just traveled with them for about half
of the trip yeah so you just took on the
chaos exactly it was an adventure okay
and I see like because you're using your
hands a lot you gotten you picked up
some of the the Italian hand gestures I
did we did get yelled at by a lot of
Italians the old Italian grandmas would
come to us after breakfast because we'd
leave something on the plate and she'd
be like you could feed an entire village
with that tell your friends and we'd be
we'd feel so wish yeah we got cursed out
a lot but it really remind me of where
we grew up and that's true yeah bring
back this which grew up uh we're
Romanian but it was like an immigrant
neighborhood
um so you know same if you don't finish
your plate that's disrespectful to the
people who made the food how's the food
in Italy I feel like uh the carbs thing
is too very yeah I think very overrated
in my opinion so I'm actually not
supposed to eat gluten because I have an
allergy yeah but I was in Italy and it's
you know gluten Galore so I was actually
eating a lot of it and it was very
interesting because I didn't get sick
while I was in Italy but I do while I'm
in the U.S so somehow
the food was actually maybe more okay
for me to digest which I appreciated but
I didn't like it as much as I thought
did you like the food there yeah no I
think it's it's uh I did I did I love
cars but it's um
it's it feels like Vegas when I go there
for the food is like if I stay here too
long I'm gonna do things I regret that's
what it feels like with the food right
because I don't know how to moderate and
everybody is pushing very large portions
and wild kind of eating things on you uh
pasta pizza and it's so good and bread
so delicious so yeah I I love it but I
regret everything so it's like I don't
wanna I don't want to go to a place
where
um I'm going to regret everything I do
for too long of a time yeah surprisingly
the people there though are still very
fit and everyone stays in good shape but
that's probably because you're walking
around all day and you're much more
active than anything and they also just
know how to moderate food I think I've
gotten used to the US way of eating the
U.S portion what is that just a lot
always a lot yeah and more and I feel in
the U.S food advertisements are also
much more in your face than you're more
often reminded of junk food than we were
in Italy so even though we were eating
less healthy things I think we're
getting cravings and being pushed
towards junk food less often